once outlawed in Cuba private businesses
are back
since 2021 Cubans have been able to
incorporate small and medium-sized
businesses more than 7 000 companies
have so far been Incorporated
Rojas Dairy employs 28 people to make
yogurt an ice cream
I think small and medium-sized
businesses have to come at the right
time for our country the economic
situation under our country today is
difficult and businesses contribute to
local development
and imports cocoa and food coloring from
abroad in a country highly dependent on
food imports the hope is that small
businesses like this will boost
productivity and get more food on
people's place
Jackson Contreras used to work as a vet
but is now one of hundreds of thousands
of Cubans working in the private sector
and earning handsomely
the difference is enormous when I worked
for the state I earned less than forty
dollars a month now I can earn around
400 to 600 a month
but in a nation where teachers and
scientists earn tiny salaries this
economist says the emergent private
sector is already attracting highly
qualified workers away from state jobs
the successful new private businesses
will provide incomes which are multiples
of what people can earn in the state
sector of course and that will cause
some important issues to be addressed
including the brain drain including the
questions of social justice access to
goods and services and so on all of
those things will arise from an increase
in inequality
[Applause]
back in the 1960s Fidel Castro banned
private businesses their owners he said
were exploiters living off their
employees labor
you don't hear language like that now
the private sector is growing in the
midst of a crisis where many State
Industries are obsolete or in disrepair
and where the state just doesn't have
enough money to supply people with the
goods they need after Decades of
anguished debate the Communist Party of
Cuba is finally moving towards a mixed
economy a growing private sector will
likely increase production but could
erode social cohesion in what is still
one of the most equal countries in the
Americas while for now the state Remains
the dominant economic force a
fundamental shift is underway Ed
Augustine Al Jazeera Maya Becca Cuba